[Music]
mr. Simpson I do vote to grant parole
when eligible and that will conclude
this carrion thank you Oh Jay fought
back tears as the Nevada parole board
voted unanimously to grant him his
freedom he'll be released on October 1st
that's 73 days from today Simpson who
was 70 years old wore jeans and a blue
button-down then he was in considerably
better shape than his last parole
hearing in 2013
I've come here spent nine years making
no excuses about anything I am sorry
that things turned out the way they did
and I would never ever pull a weapon on
anybody who was acquitted of double
murder in 1995 was convicted in an armed
robbery case involving sports
memorabilia in Nevada in 2008 this
morning Oh Jays mood went from calm to
contentious when he was asked about it
so you believe that the property was
yours it's been ruled legally by the
state of California that it was my
property and they've given it to me I
don't think she want to upset the parole
guy et watched the parole hearing this
morning with Kato Kaelin OJ's former
houseguest who testified in the criminal
trial knowing from what I've heard
before I thought he was gonna be paroled
so it's not uh it's not as a shock to me
or surprised to me at all
it's strange to hear his voice really is
it's that there's a sick devotee voices
yeah sort of chilling Simpson will serve
the minimum nine years of a 33 year
sentence I've done my time I might and
just like to get back to my family
friends and believe it or not I do have
some real friends as for what's next for
OJ well Kato hopes he will stay away
from the spotlight let's face it I think
my opinion is he got the biggest break
of his life because I thought he was
guilty in the in his murder trial and I
think he getting out of this think he
has to go down to Florida and probably
just be with his family because kids had
never be seen from again although I
don't think that's what's gonna happen
[Music]
you